we all know how much Hollywood wants to
save Africa but superstars aren't the
only ones trying to wipe out global
poverty for years NGOs and economists
have been trying to find their magic fix
and Western governments have donated
over 2.3 trillion dollars in the past 60
years in the crusade to help the world's
neediest people but many people don't
trust their rich governments to help
poor governments and why should they
political strings are attached aid helps
dictators who slaughter the very people
it was meant for so there's an
alternative well-meaning NGOs and
businesses that cut through the politics
and tackle poverty head-on but do good
intentions translate 1.3 billion people
live in extreme poverty today without
basic education in our food to eat and
access to clean water but experts say
that poverty has actually fallen over
the past 30 years
and that's true in regions like Latin
America and Asia but sub-saharan Africa
has actually gotten poorer in fact
countries in Africa make up more than
1/3 of the world's poor but why
foreign aid to Africa is billions of
dollars every year clearly there's a
disconnect between economic strategy and
what actually happens on the ground
the most common fix is what's called the
big idea once you have a successful
project you just expand it supersize it
and roll it out around the world one
size fits all and this happens all the
time take a project led by Jeffrey Sachs
a rock star of economics who works with
a-list celebrities like Bono and
Angelina Jolie in his quest to save the
world Sachs proposed the Millennium
villages project a massive experiment in
foreign aid the project gave 14
extremely poor villagers in 10 countries
money and infrastructure to jumpstart
them into self sustainability his teams
built schools health clinics and roads
but many believe his multi-million
dollar initiative was a failure in his
goal to improve these communities he
changed them in ways he couldn't predict
money food and clinics drew people from
far and wide nomadic communities turned
into shanty towns streets filled with
garbage there was theft disease spread
the project introduced cash goods and
services that change the ecosystems of
these communities we don't know what
works where or why unless these plans
are tested before during after and
constantly what might work in a town in
Uganda may not work for a community in
Kenya which is why big ideas are a big
problem and then there's innovative
businesses like TOMS they're the shoes
that flannel-wearing hipsters love to
wear when I buy a pair of pink sparkly
Tom say poor kid in Africa gets a free
pair of new shoes Sweden but critics say
that the Toms approach is only a
band-aid it actually destroys business
for local shoemakers and Tom's isn't the
only company with this model of business
rather than empower local people it
creates dependency and often competes
with local business instead of helping
the poor it may make them poorer now
these are just a few factors in the 8th
debate and there are many many more
government corruption local laws the
media and short-sighted celebrities also
tribute to the dysfunction but despite
this we can't ignore reality foreign aid
alone has never transformed a poor
country into a rich country isn't it
about time we spend more of our efforts
asking people what they need instead of
imposing our uncertain solutions